I'm trying to stray away from like
saying
escorting but obviously you
if that's what
do you consider yourself
um I consider myself more like a
adult entertainment and then just
online Persona I do YouTube I do
Instagram I do a bunch of like other
crap online so now it's just like
but you have clients that will yeah
definitely have like so many clients
that will actually want to pay and like
meet up and like do all this stuff but
I'm just you're like a sugar baby or are
you a an escort I have sugar daddies
that would want to pay for all my [__]
but that's the misconception is that
like
people not people but like the followers
want to think that people are paying for
all of my crap but the misconception is
that I have my own money and I don't
need a sugar daddy I don't need any of
that I mean of course they're fun but
like
personally
fortunately I don't need that I'm in a
good spot in my life so I don't know you
make you make good money doing this yes
100 100 how old are you now I am oh my
God you don't ask this question okay you
don't have to answer I'm like it it runs
the Illusion for like the I understand I
understand what age were you when you
started
I started maybe at 16 years old which is
obviously like clearly
illegal the age but where did you grow
up I grew up in Los Angeles California
which is what I normally tell everyone
but I've had so many stalkers and like
people that follow me all the way
upstairs to like my
room or like have waited for me at the
airport so now I just say Los Angeles
but if anyone that's been following me
for a long time they know I grew up like
Southern California like a different
County you're in New York now yeah I'm
in New York now yeah I've been living
here for one year now yeah
you like New York I love New York I'm
like debating about staying here longer
but
yeah I'm moving back to California in
like a month
what was your family like my family
lives they were super sweet I was always
like mama's boy I was like daddy's boy
like I was taking care of whatever I
asked for it was like done and done I
asked for a Playstation I had it the
next day one of the next Spider-Man game
I had it the next day so there was never
an issue there up until like I actually
came out of the closet like saying like
oh like
I'm also like gay whatever well I mean
gay is one thing but what you are is a
whole nother yeah well now now but like
back then when I was like hey and I came
out like it was crazy but now it's like
even crazier with the way that I look
and everything and then um
yeah so after I came out my parents
stopped talking to me for like a
complete month like just full-on like no
contact at all even though we were like
in the same exact house but um yeah that
was I think that was only the tough time
in my life but after that they started
like supporting me they were like very
hardcore Christians to the point where
like
they wanted to take me to like
conversion therapy and like all this
type of stuff conversion therapy yeah
which is pretty insane because I'm like
those don't work but my dad offered me a
hundred dollars to go there and so I was
like
you know what I'm Into You know I like
money you're gonna give me a hundred
dollars that's that's what I grew up on
me shopping you would no longer be gay
he was hoping that I wouldn't be gay
anymore like after commercial therapy
which I understand like I'm not
oblivious to like life like
they grew up in a different generation
so I'm not going to try to push my
beliefs on someone else that didn't grow
up at the same time as me so I'm like
okay well if you want me to go to
conversion therapy
I'll go for like a quick check but your
childhood was free of any kind of abuse
anything like that
no abuse never had a real sexual abuse
nothing like that no sexual abuse no
drama I had the best time in high school
had the best time in college what kind
of kid were you in high school
um I was like that one emo kid with like
the little like bangs and everything
which is like pretty absurd considering
how I look now but um yeah I always hang
out with like all like the hot chicks in
high school I never got bullied I never
had like any
of those unfortunate stories we all hear
about people growing up
with the tough life luckily I did not
have to face that
um sorry sorry to everyone else but um
yeah I had an amazing life like growing
up and what makes you want to make your
lips so large or your you what kind of
surgeries have you had so oh my god I've
literally had my body done like head to
toe I've had um my eyebrow lifted
upwards like that's why I have a little
lightning bolt on the side of my head
which in my mind I think it adds
character so I love my little lightning
bolt and then um I've had a rhinoplasty
I've had a lip lift I have my teeth on
clearly it's lips on obviously I've had
a full face lift I've had a
um gynecomastia which is kind of where I
started with my surgeries
my parents didn't know that I was gonna
go in for a BBL but um they thought I
was going in for like a gynecomastia
only and I never told them about the BPL
so
they were a little bit shocked about
that and then
I guess they didn't work their first
time so we did it again like a second
time
and I kind of got my ass done again
bigger yeah I got another Brazilian butt
lift and uh lift you actually made it
larger right yeah I made it larger it
wasn't even like a lift it was just like
poof like bigger everything and again I
didn't tell them what I was gonna get
done it was just like
okay well I'm gonna go to the doctor now
like whatever
um I've had arm lipo I've had leg lipo
which is another misconception is that
people think like oh your thighs don't
match like your ass and it's like Vapes
like personally from my own perspective
it's like I want my thighs not to match
my ass like I want my ass to look like
bubbles like I want like the skinniest
thighs and like just bubbles on my ass
um
I had my fall back lipo I've had my
stomach lipo or I've had a lip lift
which is where they cut up cut off like
a piece of your skin firm up here from
your philtrum and then they sew it back
up together so it's like a smaller space
so I've had everything done
we're just gonna sound crazy to other
people who don't know about surgery but
the golden ratio if you know about the
golden ratio
um like for example your Loop list is
supposed to be the size of your pinky so
if your lips touch your nose that's a
bad job but um like my pinky if it's
directly right under like my lip cell
I got golden ratio and then um
yeah lipo they're 24 Shots which they
weren't like
they weren't the legal ones they were
like the hyaluronic acid ones so that
could go away whenever I want it to go
away and I've had my ribs broken inwards
so I still haven't been tagged but
they're like not
obviously like functional so to make
your way smaller yeah to make them
smaller I'm gonna get them removed like
probably next year but yeah
and you're happy with your body now I'm
obsessed with my body right now I'm
honestly like even though my body's like
the money maker in this whole like
industry
um I'm obsessed more with like my face
because I've like truly achieved what
I've
been like not longing for because I
always had like a
not so cocky but I've always had like a
hands and face but it was just more like
oh well I want this also like why not
get it done so but I mean there's a very
feminine look to you but there's no
breasts right yeah no breasts I'm
completely I've never said this online
because I like to keep like the mill
gays or fantasies that they think I'm
like
trying to like transition if that makes
sense because I look feminine I'm not
like oblivious to that and
um yeah so I never answer really
answered that question but yeah I'm
gonna he him I'm not trying to
transition into like a woman but what do
your parents think of
where you are now
so my parents right now they love me
they literally support anything I'm into
like they're more
supportive about everything
um
they're the ones that took me to like
every single surgery I've ever had to
this day and they picked me up after
every surgery they were the ones who
were like
cared me my dad took me to my 905 when I
had her nine to five he took me into my
job for two exact for two months
straight and he took me there and I
would just lay in the back of this car
and like
stand up because we can't like sit down
when you have a BPL so he was like super
supportive
even though they're like hardcore
Christian they were like as long as my
son is happy then
I'm happy yeah if that makes sense but
you know
but your dad your parents must be aware
of who you are today and what you're
doing and all that oh yeah for sure my
dad like literally is all of my like
I don't want to say porn videos because
they're not like porn videos but um
like my only fans like amateur like
videos or whatever and he literally went
up to me one day and he was just like is
this you and me in my head thinking like
he already knew because like
I mean who's getting all this like
sexual surgery done if you're not doing
anything with that and then he asked me
the question I was I looked at him and I
was just like
yeah it looks like me that's me like why
would you second guess that and then he
literally just like stayed quiet he
walked away he didn't talk to me for
like three days and then after three
days he was just like coming back to me
he just said okay well if you're gonna
be using like the family name at least
change your name to something else like
I'm glad you're happy with what you're
doing like I'm obviously taking care of
them myself I'm paying the rent I'm
paying the food bill I'm
doing a lot of stuff for my family too
um so they were just like oh just at
least if you're gonna be doing all this
crap like
take the family name out of it I don't
want my family to like it's pretty nice
of your parents to do that yeah that was
super sweet up until like my dad told me
one time he got like really pissed off I
forgot what he told him he got really
pissed off at me and he was just like oh
like I'm never gonna show you to my
family like I don't want um
my family to see like the type of sun
that I have and I was just like oh [__]
well
I really don't give a [__] but uh that's
like his end so I was like are you
really gonna take it there because I
don't really give a [__] about like your
family either so we got into like a
little argument for a bit but um
he like finally turned a new Leaf it's
not like the word he turned a new leaf
and I'm actually gonna see meet his
family
um next week so
that's going to be interesting like
showing up like this in Mexico like
that's going to be crazy and it's not
like
Puerto Vallarta or like Cabo or like one
of these like more beach cities where
like everyone goes to the party it's
like
an actual like Mexico City so
that should be interesting yeah good
luck yeah no really and good luck to me
because when I go over there I think
like probably right after this I'm gonna
dye my hair brown and
relax a little bit more Maybe not maybe
not do my makeup and then the the lips
are what really throw it off yeah it's
the lips like the ass I could have had
it easily with like a large t-shirt like
that's fine but the lips are like the
part that I like really makes them
anxious because
um
my parents have like both told me they
don't like to go out with me like in
public because they get like really bad
anxiety and not unlike in a way that's
like um because you get so much
attention yeah exactly it's just like
the attention and not in a bad way
because they're not like
they're not embarrassed about it
obviously they don't support it but
they're more like they see all like the
bad actual stairs that like goes on with
like going out so
like in their minds they're just like
like oh that guy's like staring at you
like really hardcore like he's like
almost making fun of you like in a way
and my dad is like the type to like to
send me straight right in there and be
like no I want to walk up to this guy
and just like
you know really defend me yeah good for
your dad yeah
how did you get started started as a sex
worker how did this all begin
so this actually all began when
um
when I was on Grindr I'm not on Grindr
anymore I have a profile but I don't use
that anymore
um but I was on Grindr and then it was
me and my friend and we got a guy I
don't know how he did it but um this was
like when I was 16.
um but he offered us to fly us out to
Vegas and he just sent us like maybe I
think
three or four thousand dollars each
whatever we like book the flight and
then um
I was just like okay cute like
I don't really think anything of it I
thought it was just like a little
vacation like a mini vacation and then
we got there and he was just like oh
well like
let's start our business or whatever
we're here to do and I'm like
I'm like I thought it was just a
vacation like what are we doing here now
and then
you know the whole thing happened
already and then after that like it was
like maybe
literally just like five minutes I think
and then he gave us the money like way
back then obviously and then um
yeah so Vegas was like my introduction
into like
sex work and obviously when you're like
I say I hate saying the word underage
but like
when you're like underage like
a thousand dollars or like two thousand
dollars is like a lot for you like
that's like what back in the days you
would make in like a whole month so we
were like in Vegas just spending on like
literally everything
and I fell in love with that so you get
you you realize that something about you
can generate money yeah which is weird
because it was before I had any surgery
so I was just like
okay like something's going on out here
like I'm this was the first time I've
ever heard about like sex work or like
being flown now or like any of this and
I was like well clearly there's like a
market for this so
might as well join in if you already
have it
so
I joined and you make good money now
doing it yeah for sure yeah I literally
climbed up like the ladder like since
the start I'm at like the CEO of like um
a really big porn company at the time I
don't know if
they're still active I don't really talk
to the guy anymore but it was like
another like CEO like back in Vegas I
had my like start there he wanted me to
like become part of his company I wasn't
open to porn yet and then um
yeah it was pretty amazing everything
was like paid for like
it went smoothly
yeah
and you travel around the world yes I've
been everywhere I've been to
Egypt I've been to India I've been to
Dubai I've been to
Singapore
um Abu Dhabi Paris by myself like I
don't need anyone to come with me I'm
comfortable with how I look I don't need
anybody to come with me like when you go
to a Paris or Dubai or whatever do you
immediately just like people see you and
are attracted to you and yeah yeah
they're like yeah
either they're like attracted to me
because
no one looks like this in a different
country this is all like American like
[__] is this all American this is all
American [__] like this is either
American show to be proud of yeah either
South American obviously I'm a Mexican
so maybe that too but um like this
doesn't exist over there so there's like
a high commodity over there because they
watch like all that
American porn or whatever it is and they
want more and
I don't know personally I don't watch
too much porn myself because I'm like
I think it's a little toxic for like
people to be watching porn because it'll
just like really mess your mind up and
it just ruins like your whole
perspective like with life like if you
have a spouse and you're watching porn
like that's unrealistic it's like I
would agree with that yeah it's like why
are you watching porn that you know it's
not gonna happen with your spouse or
like someone that is Cameron ready looks
perfect and your spouse just got out of
work like that's not realistic like you
shouldn't expect your spouse or expect
reality to be porn because it's all fake
it's all
I mean I should probably not say this
because I am the one that's like feeding
the masses also like what I do but
it's just like not realistic so
personally I watch porn movie like once
a week maybe I'll take sometimes like
seven weeks like from watching porn
myself personally but I know people who
watch like porn like
three times every single day and I'm
like
from that to what like how do you
transition from
liking like a certain fetish and then
getting over it and then wanting to go
to the next level like that messes up
with your mind so much I'm like
I mean good for me good for me because
like obviously I'm making coining off of
that but
um
yeah I always think about that but I
personally don't what is your goal with
all the body modifications
so my goal I've always said like I'm
more like uh I hate the word Kendall if
anyone uses the word can with me I
literally started like throwing up it's
the most disgusting comparison to me
personally
um because I'm more like
I always say like sex cyborg sex robot
I'm more sensual I'm not in like pink
outfits and like all this like glitter
and like
obnoxious like you're not trying to be a
female yeah I'm not trying to be a
female and I'm also not that like gay
obnoxious person who's like
oh my God like let's go over here let's
do this let's do like over the top gate
yeah I'm like you can relax like I'm
more like I'm more like sexual but like
in your face kind of like this like I'm
more
[__] if you could say or
yeah something like that I'm not but but
men like this look yeah
some men I think well I know they do but
I personally think this look is a lot
more better than a Ken doll because
I mean
Kendall Barbie like I don't know that to
me is like super like trash
to me to me to me personally
in my opinion but
yeah so
like the little [__]
person you can actually take serious and
like
not think you're like in the whole
Barbie world like what kind of reaction
do you get when you're on the streets
when I'm on the streets it's like
I get so many stairs but I'm I've been
online for like
since 2014 so I'm used to like the
comments I'm used to like everything but
Street wise I get so many stairs at the
airport I have people ask me for
pictures I told you I'm like over here
like the Uber mostly positive reactions
well yeah I don't think anyone like
actually wants to like come up to me and
like be mean beat me or like tell me
[__] or like be mean
um because I have a wrestling betrays in
general so you have a resting [__] face
I have a resting [__] face like
literally if I wasn't like talking and
smiley right now I'd probably just feel
like this like
but that's just like from like all the
Botox so it's just like I can't really
move my face it's not my thing which is
another thing like bothers me because
like a lot of these people like
automatically treat me like [__] that I
meet like networking and going out and
like all this [__] because um they think
that I think I'm hot [__] so I'm gonna
treat everyone else like [__] but it's
like no babe like I'm
this is just my face I'm not like I
don't think I'm better than anyone else
in fact like my opinion for like
everyone is like
everyone should think that their their
highest form of themselves
I might like I'm like life is so short
like why are you putting yourself down
so much like just be yourself live your
life and you know like
literally like all of our problems are
so small compared to like the universe
why are people so like
judgy hateful for like something's wrong
you mentioned just a little while ago
about the comments on social media what
what's your I'm sure you get lots of
yeah you probably get a lot of hate
there I get like the most I want to pay
like I think in just a week like this
last week I got like
five videos on Tick Tock that went viral
um they all got like four plus million
views and
honestly I was personally having fun
with the comments because I was like oh
my God some of these like connect us
sure I'm like some of these [__] are
like
actually really [__] funny like they
were saying like some really dumb ass
[__] I'm like
oh what was the last one I read
um
well I can't think of the top of my head
but some of these people are actually
really funny and I'm like that's
actually so clever like I repost some of
them all like my close friends like not
even talking back to them but I'm like
wow like this one was actually really
[__] funny like whatever but I'm
personally like I've told you I've been
online for like since 2014 so you've
seen it all yeah like it's sad to say
but I'm like mentally numb to all these
comments
which is like another interesting like
thing to think about is like
um
like what does that end up happening to
a person in the long run
reading so many like negative comments
and like not thinking about it like
eventually you're gonna be like the type
of person that really just doesn't care
about like life doesn't mean do you
think it's affected that your your
personal
my view of life or of others yeah I
think it has I think because people
always like um not congratulate me but
they're like giving me my roses and
saying like oh my God you're like so
brave like um you seem pretty positive
to me yeah like I don't have like
negative energy I'm not like sad I'm not
like depressed or anything like whatever
and I get so many like messages saying
like I appreciate how like you're like
your true self like you really don't
care about these comments and like all
this stuff and I'm like
should I be caring about these comments
like I've been living like this forever
like I'm not
thinking about these comments I don't
know these people these people aren't
paying my bills like I I think you have
to factor in with hateful comments that
if if something was so upsetting you
just wouldn't watch it yeah but they're
watching it but they're watching it and
then I'm also watching the comments too
because I'm just like intriguing to see
like what people think and like all this
[__] no way they're watching it but
they're like spending the time to
comment on it so it's like it's I
believe the comments are more of a
reflection on the commenter than on the
subject of the comment exactly so that
I've always said that like even though
people
maybe watching this or maybe have seen
me before or like really judgmental and
like all that crap I'm like
you think you know what you're saying
but I know on the top of my head like I
know more about like the human race in a
way because of how much like judgment I
get myself I know how people
think and just how some nasty people can
be and I'm just like
even though people are going to be like
oh love yourself like you're in sick
you're forgetting all these surgeries
I'm like looking the way I looked look
and seeing these comments I'm like I
think you're probably more insecure
actually taking the time of your life to
leave a comment to me I'm living my best
life I'm not bothering anyone I'm being
like my ordinary self so I'm like
in reality who here is sad I have I've
never taken the time to like leave a
hate comment like I think that's like
the lowest like
level of human possible ever like to
live an anonymous hateful comment is is
just and some of these aren't people
like that are anonymously do I've
clicked on a profile just to like see
like what's up um and some of these
people have like in their bio like
love God
um love body positivity and I'm like
you love body positivity and people
loving themselves if it's according to
like your beauty standards but if it's
something you don't agree with you're
not hurting anybody like what am I
literally doing I'm not like out here
like
sorry it's like such a bad example I'm
not out here like stabbing people like
I'm just I mean you're not hurting
anybody yeah you're trying to beautify
yourself so some people find what you
are is very attractive yeah you enjoy it
I enjoy it nothing wrong with that
that's another misconception also which
is people think that I'm like
trying to like fix something fix
something and I'm like I'm not fixing
anything you could look back you could
ask my friends from high school I have
always thought I was a hot [__] and then
again I'm gonna say it again
so it doesn't get like cut up or
whatever online but I think personally
everyone should think that they are hot
[__] like you who's
like whose other life are you gonna live
beside yourself
you're on this Earth just once in your
lifetime think you're hot [__] like
whatever don't think don't think you're
better than anyone ever like that's the
stuff do you ever wake up and look at
maybe your ass or your lips or whatever
and go oh my what am I doing
um you ever doubt yourself I've never
doubted myself which is what I love
about me because like that's why I
that's why I think my comments don't get
to me because when I look in the mirror
I see exactly what I wanted it for
myself since before I had money since
before I had um surgeries any of that so
I'm like I wake up
completely fine I wake up like perfect
I'm like oh like
stunning like whatever like I just wish
more people
knew how to love themselves
which the world would be a great place
it sounds pretty stupid because I had
like 70 like plus surgeries I spent so
much money on like surgeries but like
people leading to learn how to like love
themselves like everyone be happy there
will be negativity like
it would just be like an amazing world
but some people just can't shut up and
like live their life
so I don't know emotionally do you ever
get depressed
emotionally no I have not been depressed
in like years probably like since high
school really yeah yeah it's been like a
long ass time drugs are not part of your
life no like at most at most I'll take
like
um alcohol tequila yeah and that's about
it yeah but everything else sounds like
super against I don't do like any
well now that I live in New York like I
know all these drugs are but like back
when I lived back home I don't know what
any of this was but like I don't do
ketamine I don't do like
um
meth I've heard people do out here but I
assume the crowd that you're hanging out
with the clubs you're going to and stuff
like that are probably those drugs are
prevalent right yeah they're it's like
normal here which I think is insane like
people do like G like do you know what G
is yeah it's like a
a date rape like type of drug and people
over here like make it so normal and I'm
like
I believe that's like literal like acid
goings on your throat like people use
this to like rape people out in like the
world and this is more normal to you
than like alcohol I'm like
I don't know like I'm gonna stick to
alcohol y'all can relax I don't need any
of that crap to like get into it I've
obviously like dived into like some
drugs but like I'm not I don't have that
addictive personality myself
I'm not addicted to plastic surgery
either it's just like
what I want it's just like if you want
like a
let's say like a a baseball cap you've
been eyeing for like a while except for
me it's like surgery I'm gonna go buy it
and get it like it's not like a I don't
see it as a big deal it's just like okay
I'm gonna go get it and that's it so
what would you say is your greatest
strength
my greatest strength I think is
that exact like same thing we were just
talking about earlier it's like I
confidence it's confidence it's the
mindset like if I'm happy like why do
you care about comments why do you care
about people I look at the stairs I've
seen like some actual like nasty stairs
and I'm just like
okay well that's his problem like that's
his
probably not in insecurity I know how I
look I'm not oblivious to how it looks
like I know I look different so maybe
that's just like
I'm conscious of how it looks so I
understand his perspective but it
doesn't bother me because I'm happy with
who I am as a person I know what I mean
and that's I think the one issue that I
really do have with life is like people
just look at me and they don't hear any
word I say all they see is like
plastic surgery the physical crap like
all the comments I get I could literally
like read the whole Bible like however
many freaking pages are on the Bible
like 100 pages of the Bible and all the
comments would probably just be like
ah trash like oh you got Bosh you got
this you got that like you look so nasty
and I'm like
people I just read you the whole Bible
like you it went one ear and out the
other so that's really the only issue I
have but like deep down we're all human
like I don't
I personally don't think I'm like a
Looney Tune in the head so I'm just like
I don't see where people come with these
type of comments personally are there
other surgeries you're looking to have
done
yeah I'm looking uh um after I just said
I'm not Looney uh I'm not gonna get like
my ribs like fully taken out because
right now they're like
broken in words but they're not taking
out fully so they're still intact
they're just
sorry it's gonna sound so vulgar but
like they're so like hanging on to like
the meat that they're normally at
um and then probably go hair transplant
I want to get my lips and bigger
um and
may go bigger on my ass and
that's about it like honestly that's a
really short list for like what I've
already had done personally but
yeah it's not like something that I'm
like desperate to like go get done like
I'm like incredibly happy with like
how they look what kind of guy is
attracted to you what kind of
see and that's what I mean by like it's
porn is such an addiction to some people
again I don't have a addictive
personality myself but
um
it's just a type of people who have
already done like
I don't know what straight people
um think is like major like spitting
like pissing like I don't know what
street people do
um but once they're like bored with uh
they're ready to like move to like uh
I don't know like a trans person or
something once they're born with that
like trance is already like such a big
like porn industry thing but once
they're done without they're ready for
like the next big thing which should be
like what I am which is not trans I'm
like literally like in the middle and
I'm not gonna be trans I'm never gonna
transition so
everyone can like relax because that's
all I got
um so I'm in the middle of like both
genders I am
I've never said this online because I
hate to ruin the fantasy but I'm like he
him I'm not like
it or whatever the pronouns people they
start coming up with nowadays
um so they're ready like just for like
the next the next big thing so I get
like those type of like
freaky people which I love because
it's gonna make me sound so old but like
when I see a guy get like really horny
it like makes me like
I don't know it like gives me life
I sound like I'm like 40 years old but
I'm like okay you can turn somebody on
yeah like just knowing that or like
they're just like super into it just
like gives me like energy
have you been in love before
um maybe
twice
but that was about it
um
the first one
I don't want to say the last name
because then I you might not see me
tomorrow but um yeah he was like a
really
it's like a really big banking name
um they like basically like run the
world and I was dating him for like a
year everything went fine
um
but I hate to like stereotype myself
since I'm like Mexican but I have like
that like Latino spiciness like very
clingy so he broke up with me for that
and I don't mind it
um and then my next one he did want me
to do like sex work which is completely
fine I wouldn't want my partner to do
sex work either
um but he was like
I don't want you to do sex work I'm like
I think a year later he started doing it
and I'm like
you little unfortunate soul like
you clearly
don't know what you want for yourself in
your life and I'm like I even back then
back when I was like 18 I'm making
myself sound so old um back when I was
um like
I already knew what I wanted in my life
and the fact that this guy didn't even
know yet and now that he's in his
whatever age I haven't talked to him
forever he's like starting sex work I'm
like
girl like some of these people like
really need to learn
not learn people really need to like
have their own space on their own time
by themselves and figure themselves out
because I have all of my trips to buy
Egypt's Paris
um prices in a big deal actually
um
Abu Dhabi I did it by myself I didn't
need a companion or nothing I do
everything by myself I've never had any
of my trips paid I do
All My Things by myself so I'm just like
so secure with my own personal selves
looking like this
like this and I'm
I don't know like people are so like far
behind to where
that sounds so cocky to say but like
my mentality is like over here and like
when I see people I'll make your
mentalities like down here like I'm not
gonna tell you your face but I'm like
you have so much potential and you're
just not letting it out so I just hope
people get in 50 years we'll all be
doing this to our bodies yeah well not
to the bodies no I I'm like I'm
obviously Pro plastic surgery for myself
but I'm not like I always push against
plastic surgery I have so many friends
like ask me for advice for like oh I'm
insecure about like my teeth or whatever
like how do I get veneers and I'm like
no like there's better options like I
always thought I have crowns not veneers
and I'm like no there's like composite
um
Composites or something like that
um and I just show them like a better
route like you don't need to go this way
like I had I'm like oh I have people who
want like their arms like smaller I'm
like baby you don't need anything you're
perfect like I don't expect people to
like be like surgery surgery surgery
like I'm
not that type of person I'm just more
like
I'm more about myself I keep to myself I
do my own thing and I think that's the
only way I've been able to like stay
relevant is like because I keep changing
like every single year
I've been online since 2015 so
um but yeah I'm not like for plastic
surgery I'm just like
if you could do anything else like just
stay away from class to the dream it's
like the scariest crap ever like
what do you think the world needs more
of
I just think finding themselves
open-mindedness people are so
narrow-minded and more accepting yeah I
just
accepting I guess yeah accepting would
be a better word um if they understood
they'd probably accept because they
don't want to think and understand like
my parents through
um
they don't support what I do or they
don't like all the surgeries but um
they do support my happiness which is
all I can ask for what am I gonna tell a
person that's like 50 years old like
we're from a different generation like
I'm not gonna be here here like shoving
down like
surgery done your throat like
I guess people call it like the gauge
under or something like shoving the
gauge and they're down their throat I'm
like no like I'm gonna be happy with
whatever you can like
um
I guess take
um yeah because I mean
I wish more people knew about that too
because I hate seeing stories about like
kids being so like
depressed that their parents aren't
accepting them and I'm like
babe they're like triple your age like
relax they don't have to accept who you
are as a person as long as they love you
that's fine just leave it there like
stop trying to change their mind
they're already like
I hate being dramatic but like they're
already like almost to their they're
almost like their deathbed like just
relax live as happy as you can with your
parents and
your life will be like so much better
stop
putting this narrative with people that
don't have the same beliefs as you and
it's fine just you really need to listen
to your own you know march to your own
drummer exactly exactly live this life
don't you yeah you really do can't be a
conformist you can't be listening to
what other people think yeah and that's
like another thing that like pisses me
off like about like the whole like gay
thing is like oh
not the gay thing but like some people
like
want to see it like on TV shows or they
want to see it on like movies or like
there's not enough gay representation
I'm like
oh it doesn't need to be everywhere like
you don't need to put it in movies you
don't need to like
put it everywhere just like live your
best life like why are you shoving this
crap down everyone's throat we all know
the normal thing is to be a stray like
that's how you make babies or whatever
like stop shoving it down everyone's
throat as I'm wearing like fishnets out
in public or whatever but um yeah I just
think people need to relax and I would
say the same thing for like anything if
it's like
gender race
um straight people are trying to shove
their shits on our throats too but it's
like
just let like
life go on like stop trying to change
the world the world will change with you
like it'll happen eventually maybe not
in our generation but as long as you
love yourself and you're confident it
event eventually the world will love
with you like it's not that serious
we're not
Gonna Change the World in like two days
or as I always say it's like Rome wasn't
built in one day like
relax it's gonna happen maybe not your
generation but as long as you can do
your thing and like be confident in
yourself like
it's gonna happen eventually like I've
helped so many other people like just be
more comfortable with themselves even if
they don't believe in surgeries they're
just like
well like you really inspired me to like
dress a certain way or just like go out
be confident whatever and they're not
like supporting like the whole like
plastic surgery scene there's more like
wow like I love how you're genuinely
yourself individual yeah an individual
and I'm not like afraid of it either I'm
just like
doing me if that makes sense yeah so I
just hope
people can get to that point at some
point I don't think it's gonna happen
during my lifetime but
um
I'm doing my work so hopefully everyone
else can do their part also and just
live their best life
all right Mateo thank you so much for
sharing your story of course I wish you
all the luck in the world thank you
thank you very much